good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's the
last week of pizza miss that means
there's only a few more days to get your
pizza and stuff at pizzamist.com
including all of our amazing t-shirts in
this super snuggly blanket and this
color changing mug by the way we now
have some discount bundles including the
Cozy bundle which includes this blanket
in the mug for thirty dollars off okay
hang so full disclosure I'm anxious so
let's go outside because it does
actually help me to like touch grass and
be amid trees it's so weird to me how
much life there is on earth like this is
life this is life this is life you made
a tick tock once where you pointed out
that humans have relatively brief
lifespans and our species hasn't been
around for that long but if we think of
ourselves as part of one continuous
biological phenomenon called life then
things start to look quite different
because life on Earth has existed
continuously for about
3.7 billion years which is around 23
percent of the history of the entire
universe so like we are young and most
species we currently share the planet
with are fairly young like even the
Tuatara which existed before the
emergence of large dinosaurs is only
around 250 million years old Which is
less than 10 percent of the history of
life on Earth so yeah where new most
other things that we see are new but
life is very old and I do find that a
little comforting but when you're
walking through an urban-ish Forest you
don't only see Life of course you also
see steel husks and concrete structures
that were once used to house barrels of
whiskey during prohibition this Forest
used to be private property owned by
Albert Lieber who made and lost a
fortune selling booze and who was also
the grandfather of the novelist Kurt
Vonnegut and we're in a city so the
human-shaped world is everywhere even in
the forest from the invasive Ivy to the
extraordinarily polluted White River
there's no full separation between these
worlds not really we try to claim that
this is artificial and this is natural
but concrete and steel are made out of
Earth just like everything else is all
right I'm starting to breathe a little
easier I'm part of a continuous process
of life that stretches back a quarter of
the way to the beginning of time and I'm
in a world I'm walking this is a good
place to be all things considered It's a
Good Earth my friend Henry in Sierra
Leone likes to say that when he sees
beauty or goodness in the world that he
is encouraged so yeah I'm feeling
encouraged one nice thing about
Indianapolis in October the leaves are
starting to fall if you pitch this idea
to someone who'd never been to Earth I
think they would find it phenomenally
beautiful so each cycle we would explain
to these non-earth folk each cycle it
gets colder in parts of our world as we
tilt away from our Star and our most
numerous and Visually prominent life
forms which are called trees Simon
continuously change the fluttering soft
green appendages at the end of these
trees are called leaves and these leaves
erupt into bright colors that we
associate with our star Reds oranges
yellows and then huge swaths of leaves
fall to the ground until the ground is
covered with them the trees spend the
cold months without their leaves and
then as our Earth begins to tilt back
toward its star the trees regrow their
leaves this goes on growing and falling
growing and falling for dozens or even
hundreds of Cycles it goes on for so
long that leaves dropped by Young trees
may in time become soil that helps
support that same tree as it gets older
in a very real way our trees are
nourished by what they let go of by what
they leave behind
what an encouragement I find that to be
Hank I'll see you tomorrow